it's an honor to be here today thank you
so much for inviting me I'm gonna do my
best to tuck for a short period of time
which is it'll hard for me because I've
been asked to leave time to break out
into session so I'll do my best but I'm
going to talk about feeds today i'm i
think feeds are one of the more recent
exciting things about social computing
and social media systems and they're not
fraught without their fraught with
controversy sometimes but there's so
many so many pros to them this is a
snapshot of twitter twitter how many of
you are not familiar with twitter so I
don't have to ok great so there's
something some interesting algorithmic
phenomena that happened with Twitter
Twitter introduced you look at it you
don't realize how much algorithms might
be playing a role here but there's a
trending feet here in Twitter in Twitter
and it's changed over the years in the
beginning everybody saw the same trends
one day Twitter decided to change the
Twitter algorithm and instead of seeing
Justin Bieber tweeting trending at the
top as it had been for six months or so
overnight lots of teenage girls were
shocked that their favorite singer was
no longer there Twitter then had to
publicly announce that they had to
change the algorithm so that they could
get some valleys and some smaller Peaks
that weren't just the big phenomena
these girls got so upset that they
decided to come up with the code and
instead of tweeting about Justin Bieber
who they knew would be somewhat blocked
they started tweeting about G BER and
just swapping the first two letters of
his first and last names and the guy him
trending again so people when when they
realize most people realize is an
algorithm and a feed when it breaks they
don't often realize until that happens
but we see feeds in our daily life this
is an example of Google News and here
you actually have some control over your
feet so that gives you an idea that
there's some algorithm of algorithmic
play there this is a snapshot of
Pinterest
I'm sorry pallav or similar to Pinterest
and one might wonder like why am I
seeing this dress this dress first why
am I not seeing this drum kit first this
is an example of Behance one of Adobe's
social media sites and this one I think
is there something into
thing about the ambiguity here because
in some ways the ambiguity of what you
see in a feed could be helpful do you
read this left-to-right
do you read this tapped it down what
does it mean if something's on the lower
right hand corner versus in the upper
left hand corner and we're seeing feeds
in our daily lives even more like what
happens when feed start going into our
health domain and while going to the
cafeteria and the feed says while your
friend James just had a salad why are
you eating this burger so thinking about
feeds I think is kind of important to
think about how they are going to flow
into our daily lives which they already
are even beyond that you see this
interesting prioritization happening
let's say I want to take a class on
Coursera it suggests I take this class
here what about some other classes that
might be of use to me what is it that
prioritizes some classes over others and
when and if how can we find out if
there's any any play of somebody paying
to move something to the top of a list
for many many studies have shown so far
that you cannot tell when something is
sponsored on Facebook even though it's
listed there people just don't realize a
difference but what I'm really
passionate about is Social Feeds when
people talk to one another this is a
snapshot from Facebook in I mean this
this feat is incredible how many of you
used Facebook in 2006 when it first came
out or 2004 I think is when it first
came out if I'm not mistaken okay a few
of you so the feet did not exist then
when it first came out it was called the
wall and prior to that you know you'd
find your friends on Facebook it was
very similar to Friendster and and
you're almost done you're almost done
then they introduced the feed which got
really bad backlash when it first came
out people were furious they're like how
dare they keep posting these these
updates like I don't want people to know
what I'm doing I don't want to have to
always be on and keep posting things but
in many ways that was one of the most
brilliant things they could have done it
was very reminiscent of the Piazza in
Italy the Agora in Athens this idea of a
place to go to see and be seen I mean
one of the things that I think is more
brilliant about is it's a place you can
go to and be alone and actually be
social while you're alone it's great for
introverts but you can also go there
with somebody else and actually have
a more synchronous style of interaction
and it's it's helped bring people back
again and again I'm I'm quietly
confident and increases page views but
people enjoy it and there's been many
studies showing how if you are a
producer on Facebook it's better for
your mental health it helps you if your
consumer solely there might be some
effects that are less understood and
even beyond that I've always been a
really big fan of the work by Jim
Holland in store Nedim and they wrote
this one paper where they looked at some
of the the connection needs that humans
that human requirements which were met
encourage and facilitate interaction and
of these they came up with cue variety
by aggregate millas work feedback
message personalization simultaneously
being reminded me to talk to someone
having a common communication channel
turn-taking repair sized openings and
the Facebook feed has all of these when
they were writing this paper beyond
being there they were thinking about in
your telepresence environments but this
feat is this alternate form of
communication that captures all of that
that said I was still struggling to
understand it I was captivated
captivated by it and didn't get it and
then one day sitting around with
colleagues you know the wonderful
Christensen vague Kevin Hamilton Cedric
Lambert we were staring at this one one
thing and Christian had posted this
there's a big crystal for her pen and we
could not figure out why it was at the
top of our feeds for so many weeks what
was it about this one post that moved it
to the top and if you look at it it's
actually a parody post the reviews are
it's more of a performance piece than an
actual thing that you buy on Amazon but
it moved to the top and we couldn't
figure out why and you had four people
that were college educated trying to
make sense of why this was happening we
made our own Facebook groups tried to
like things we made pages trying to
figure out what we could do to move
things to the top and we couldn't do it
so we decided to study it further in our
attempts to do that we decided to go to
the approach of what we call the
narrative visualization where we take
people subjects on a tour of their feed
and then oh I just realized came
I have a snapshot of James saying
something from a long time ago there was
an intentional that we thought we
thought we walk people through a feed
and and see what they thought not tell
them anything just take them on this
guided journey and so we did
Mota Harry islami built this tool called
feed vis and what you're seeing here is
on the left you're seeing all the posts
you would have seen if every single
person on your on your Facebook network
had posted something you would seen
everything for me when you're Network on
the right we put using the API the
things that appeared on your feed and so
what you're seeing here
anything that's blue a light blue here
appeared in your feed so you're already
starting to see some holes here I didn't
see that cliff Lampe like the post here
you can see again I saw all of these but
anything that's white I missed so I
missed you know three four posts here
for most people in our study this was
the first time that had any idea that
they didn't see everything from their
network the first thing they realized
scrolling down was that this column here
was roughly three times as long as this
column on the right we then took them to
the next stage where we let them see
posts from their friends we connected
this to a human to a person and here on
the Left what you're seeing is people we
just randomly chose three people whose
posts you never see three people where
you roughly see half of their posts and
three people where you see most of their
posts and you can refresh this button
and keep seeing this list keeps growing
and growing and growing and again many
people for the first time realized that
they had never seen posts from any of
the people in this list they saw roughly
some posts from people and it's roughly
half of post people in this list and
many of the posts most of the posts from
people in this list and it got them
trying to think about why is this
happening people particularly got
viscerally angry if there was a family
member in this column or this column and
they didn't see their posts and we were
exploring their that different levels of
awareness and of the people who were
unaware they're like oh I bet I didn't
see that asking them beforehand I bet it
would be on my newsfeed I probably would
at some point during the day or so I
probably don't scroll down enough but
you know you can't always scroll down so
much you just kind of go like a few
posts is that if I want to go back to
mystery it's probably accessible I
probably find it if I took the time
so most people essentially blame
themselves for not seeing a post their
different paths to awareness
some people inductively compared feeds
for why they view like I have like 900
some friends and I only see 30 of them
so something's going on there
some had more deductive reasoning
there's too much material in general so
you're not gonna see all of it and then
we were trying to explain why some
people understood and why some didn't
and we looked at some features and we
discovered that it didn't matter how
long you're on Facebook didn't matter
the percentage of your scene versus
total content the network size did not
matter what didn't matter was how often
you used Facebook your activity level if
you're a heavy poster if you'd ever made
a Facebook page or managed a group so
for example there were some bar owners
that we interviewed that actively tried
to get people to their pages and they
were very very clever about how they did
that and also if you had a Facebook page
you also get an email from Facebook
giving you statistics about the usage
patterns and people who would use the
comment one thing that was interesting
is at the top and recent stories there's
actually a button on Facebook and people
most people assume that you always see
Facebook stories chronologically but it
turns out the default is that you see
top stories and even if you move it to
chronological it'll default back to top
stories after some time so when the
study was done in 2014 2013 2014 roughly
only 37 point 5 percent of people were
aware of the algorithm behind the
Facebook newsfeed the reactions that we
got were pretty interesting and again
people were quite angry and I want to
stress initially so do they actually
hide these things from me mentioning the
unseen stories one person is the
metaphor of the matrix it's 10 it's kind
of intense because you've seen the movie
the matrix it's kind of like waking up
in the matrix in a way I mean you have
what you think of as a reality of like
what they choose to show you and then
the what the hell Facebook and then lots
of words we couldn't print
on the screen people were originally
very very angry and for many of them it
was uncovering some misperceptions and
they were getting these lightbulb
moments like I know she had some family
issues so I just thought she deactivated
her account
that was her explanation for why they
didn't see any of her posts I've never
seen her post anything and I always
assumed that I wasn't really that close
to that person so that's fine
but what the hell and then there were
different expectations that came out as
they were talking to us through this
almost like a therapy session some
people were upset they didn't see
somebody's post asking for help because
they really felt that they could help
that person and this came up again and
again and again I think she needs
support for that mentioning tonight some
story if I see it and I will say
something to support her and what's
really interesting to me there is that
the Facebook literary sub supports that
that you can help people actively by
producing content online and by having
discussions with them for now I can't
really understand how they categorizes
people actually says my brother and
actually he needs to be here moving in
from one column to another so people
were really angry we kept them in the
room and then we had a second part of
the study where we showed them all the
people and that's in which category they
wanted we wanted them they wanted the
people to be in like should this person
this person was categorized as mostly
seen should they be in one of the other
two columns and we did the same thing
for content so for example this was
these were seen posts but you could
click on it if you did not want to see
it and these were unseen posts and you
can click on it if you really had wanted
to see it and it turns out that finally
people are actually kind of okay with
their feed the majority of the folks
have comments akin to a lot of what is
filtered out are just things that don't
really met pertain to me I'm so grateful
because otherwise it would clutter up
what I really want to see or honestly
have nothing to change which I'm
surprised because I came in like oh
they're just screwing at all and so
through this course of this narrative
visualization people were changing their
minds and I'm again I'm going very
briefly of this I'm not talking about
the Sampo I'm not talking about the
length of the study if you have
questions please ask feel free to
interrupt as I'm talking but I just want
to sort of get at the at the gist of
this and the other thing we discovered
throughout this as they were talking is
they were all giving us all
these folk theories for why this was
happening and this got me really
interested because in graduate school
I'd been introduced to the shaman named
Kempton and he discovered this
coexistence of folk theories and
institutional theories in his work he
studied thermostats and he explored two
theories of sermons that he interviewed
a bunch of people and found that they
primarily fell into two camps there's
one group of people that believed they
call it the feedback theory that the
thermostat was a switch that once the
temperature got too low your heat would
kick on other people thought the
thermostat was more like a valve so
almost like the sink that if you turn it
on more it gets hotter faster and what
other things that was really interested
in or interesting in his findings
it's interviewing all these people and
then looking at logs of the usage
patters all the of these thermostats is
he found that each of the abstracted
theories produced inefficiencies and
advantages so there are people that so
the experts say widely agree that it's
more of a switch theory not a valve
theory and get some of the people using
the valve theory had more efficient heat
usage we found the exact same thing with
a theories that people were making for
their Facebook feeds so before the probe
we interviewed people who are aware that
there was an algorithm there and they
came up with four general theories this
personal engagement theory about how
involved I get in my feet global we
called it a global popularity theory a
format theory and narcissus theory and
if you want more detail I can refer you
to a paper what I want to get here with
with this is showing that how many more
theories arose after they used their
narrative visualization and what's
interesting is that after even the
unaware folks use a narrative
visualization they all came up with the
exact same theories after the fact so by
using the tool we got the unaware folks
and they aware of folks thinking along
the same lines after the follow-up we
came back and talked to folks two to six
months later and one of the things that
we found was that roughly 80% of the
people had a same or higher satisfaction
with their feed than they had before I'm
more interested in checking Facebook
because it does not seem as cluttered
with right of information because I
don't know that not everything I post
everyone else will see I feel less
snubbed when I make posts they get
minimal or no response it feels less
personal and again there were some
people that had lowered satisfaction
because
I'm disappointed because I keep thinking
that I might be missing some updates
from friends but overall people reported
that they kept going back to Facebook
more and more American this is self
report and they kept reporting that they
were more conscious of what they did in
their free to try to get what they
wanted to appear at and many people
actually come to the feed was better
because of their more active and careful
participation and so some of the
hypotheses that arose from this were
that you know algorithm awareness
increased engagement for our users
people did not want a full model of how
this algorithm worked they didn't care
they didn't want 700 plus features to
follow they wanted a general idea if if
I do this then this might happen
and we've done this alternative excuse
me same interaction experience was very
very helpful to them and they wanted to
keep using this tool after the fact note
it's not that sort of tool you would use
all the time but something you might
want to use at intervals which then that
is to the question of should users even
be aware of the role of algorithms and
filters and their new sources and if so
how in addressing that how three general
approaches have been used so far people
have been trying to undo the bias or
their prioritization and feeds for
example in Facebook one might argue that
one way to undo this it's just as always
put everything in most recent mode so
you see everything chronologically
however it's not clear that that makes
it unpriced or unbiased what does it
mean to like for example what does it
mean to unbias a twitter feed from
politics what does it mean to unbiased
something it's a very difficult problem
that's fraught with its own issues of an
algorithm done by something that you
then have to interrogate as well second
approach people uses make the viewer
aware of the prioritization explicitly
or abstractly which is approach that
we're embracing and three is to allow
the user to create their own
prioritization algorithms and I'm going
to talk briefly about the latter two
here so in terms of seams and
transparency our approach the social
visualization that we use us the
narrative visualization used it the seam
a side-by-side comparison where I
created a rigid schism in the center for
years you know many people argued for
more seamless interfaces and this was
considered like the norm or actually the
epitome what you strive for and this is
an exempt
of orbits very simple interface you put
in your origin put in your destination
you get a very nice Lick ordering you
try to choose the top one that you like
this to was fraught with controversy
there was a time when they were it was
discovered that if you're using an OSX
system you are getting more expensive
flights first and if you're using a
different type of system and it took a
long time for people to realize this
because it wasn't expected there was
nothing in the interface to say to you
look because you're using a Mac or
because you're doing this you're not
getting this interface there was these
expectations that people held an
alternative approach which is much more
sinful is the kayak approach and when I
first saw kayak I didn't like the
aesthetic of it at all to be honest with
you I'm not sure that I'd like the
aesthetic today but what's interesting
about it is it inspires trust in people
because it actually pops up the sources
for where you get their data and you see
it changing in real time and it gives
you some hints it shows you this this
slight reveal and this idea of simple
interfaces is not ours
the first paper read about it was by
gentleman named Matthew Chalmers and he
was the classic example he was looking
at edges and gaps nado to coverage and
by showing people these edges and gaps
and coverage of whether it be telephone
network or Wi-Fi network it made people
smarter and more intelligent about their
choices of how they use the system and
they became more expert users so the
feet of his system in some way provided
this seemed it showed you these holes
here for what you didn't see it so
there's this contrast scheme here and
you're starting to see a few more of
these sort of like comparison systems
today this was a visualization made by
the Wall Street Journal would they use
Facebook's data to actually categorize
something as being more liberal or more
conservative keep in mind this also has
an algorithm in it there's like a meta
level here of an algorithm being used to
interrogate a different type of
algorithm moving to the third approach
oh Michael is it sort of like unzipping
and seeing inside of it like you're
seeing like what it's not showing you or
is it is the seam about like where the
edge of where the system breaks down so
what what did you think about seams I
think
is where you reveal something that was
not meant to be seen it's often think
thought of as a mistake so for example I
think some of the best seems like if I
if I had charge of Facebook for a day I
would make a glitch day where I would
say that they leave the print statements
in and you can say it's like printf
number of people who saw this page is
that so that's an example of a seam an
example of a seam is where you make a
reveal for something that might people
might think of as a mistake or might not
want to show you for example if you're
showing a feed of what you actually saw
you wouldn't also see what everyone else
showed you but if is some third party
build a tool like this it's simple
because it's different than what I would
have you that they could also do it by
revealing something that normally wasn't
revealed before so it's it's a it's a
temporal change there they didn't do it
in the past by doing it today it becomes
a scene because I didn't do it yesterday
it was a moment in our work we found
that the side-by-side comparison is one
of the most powerful ways to see
something in an algorithm the idea
moving to the third approach of using
creating your own calibrating your own
algorithm is something that we toyed
with in 2009-2010 with the brilliant
eric gilbert he made this tool called we
metal and the idea here was that he was
exporting algorithms for tie strength
and he made this widget here where he
actually did some social zooming so if
you move this widget towards the inner
circle you saw more twitter posts from
your inner circle if you move that
little line down to your outer circle
you some are posting your outer circle
but you actively made that decision and
you can also choose other parameters
here from communities that were created
using some simple matrix clustering and
we got lots of amazing comments about
this interface people were using an over
twitter as their daily twitter reader
we got a small fan base in south korea
for some reason that we don't understand
and notice here though that in terms of
creating the interface there's more than
just these controls there's more than
these like two panels of control panels
look at the typeface look at the flow
we're changing we're changing the type
pace here so for example by moving that
scroll bar the type plot becomes more
bold it becomes more of a serif font and
instead of a sans-serif font so you're
looking at this page you're like wait a
second this person is different than
that person there's level of
communication happening here that
something is different about this post
than the post below it or the one below
that and so we're trying to communicate
using typeface that not all tweets here
are created equal
and using this control planet approach
is exactly what what Google is doing
here with our Google News and now more
so Twitter is starting to adopt this
typeface approach where if you have
something that has more likes or more
retweets they're actually changing the
typeface for you to give you some idea
that something is happening another
approach that might be useful is to
maybe borrow other people's algorithms
so there was a system I don't think it's
around today how many of you have ever
used a system called trove it was
created by commander taco who is amazing
and the idea here is so look I can't
figure out Facebook's algorithm but
maybe I really really like you know
Michaels tastes and so I can adapt part
of Michael's algorithm and say I want a
little bit of Michael's algorithm I'm a
little bit of Joyce algorithm a little
bit of Justin's algorithm and then I
create my old algorithm that way and so
what I'm trying to do here is I'm trying
to bring in some of the beyond being
there from what's obvious about the
Twitter feed that we've had so far
like the chronological order and saying
like we can create some our own
approaches and as long as we understand
them abstractly that might be enough
that also leads to bias this is another
interface that we created trying to show
bias and tweets and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about that for a second
and so in terms of bias we were trying
to understand which tweets were more
liberal and which tweets were more
conservative similar to the Facebook
project that that or The Wall Street
Journal project they use the Facebook
data
but in exploring Twitter data we found
something that we thought was quite
interesting not unexpected but quite
interesting we were looking at all the
input data that we had and this is doing
Twitter query search so you put in a
search for Twitter you see what comes
out it turns out that when you do query
searches over political topics
predominantly most of the data in all of
Twitter's Democratic to begin with so
here what does it mean to talk about
bias if most of your data is biased from
one way what is it me to talk about a
bias of the ranking algorithm if your
input data is biased take that one more
step thinking about learning algorithms
what does I mean if you have an
algorithm if your training set is biased
one way your training set is very much
gonna influence the output of your
algorithm and so we were looking at
putting in queries and seeing what
happened to them and what we found at
least for the period of 2015 of december
on twitter is that it's very hard to be
republican if you think of this as a
scale of your affiliation democrat being
one and republican being -1 and I
apologize for that labeling we had to
choose one or the other and zero being
neutral if you had an input let's look
at the very top one so if you're Donald
Trump and the input bias was 0.19 so
anything about Donald Trump was roughly
skewed Democratic once they got through
the ranking algorithm it became even
more democratic so it was really hard to
be a Republican in December of 2015 and
it's not clear what it means to remove
this by it so when I talked about
earlier about removing a bias what does
it mean to remove a bias in this case we
don't know how do you explain yeah yeah
so it could be me it could be an
intentional design decision or it could
be a secondary effect of the behavior on
Twitter for example Democrats retweeting
the things about Donald Trump that the
ranking system catches like oh it's
popular so the antenna right
it's controlling for retweets popularity
[Music]
the social signals that they transfer
the same yeah and and can mean and this
also controlled for example like number
of followers or Network position of
position know the trends are very
similar at the end of the day though
there's a self-selection here going on
in terms of the content that's on
Twitter and that we don't know I don't
know how to unpack that I think that's a
great question for future research but
this is one case that we found here and
so one of things that I want to mention
in looking at this bias is one bias is
important but we only shouldn't look at
the algorithm bias we have to look at
the data the training data we have to
look at the input bias as well which
leads me to a slightly bigger question
about bias online and algorithmic
systems so whoever was at lunch today
I've talked about this very briefly but
there's lots of different sites that
that have feet so example let's say I go
onto Zillow and I look for a house I
might get an ordering of of homes there
let's say I go to homes calm let's say I
go to Giulio there's so many different
sites out there a bias there not only
has you know implications for
relationships but also has legal
implications because it's because it's
illegal you know for in fair housing
with Kristensen Vick
Kevin Hamilton again and Cedric Lambert
we're exploring fair housing our racial
minorities less likely to find housing
be algorithmic matching systems in
November of 2016
Adelman at Harvard wrote this wonderful
paper looking at Airbnb and showing that
if you're black you don't get the offers
that white people get for rooms he also
showed earlier in a different study that
if you're a black landlord you don't
make as much money as a white landlord
would make for the same unit if it's
controlled for location square footage
and so forth so there's a clear evidence
of algorithmic bias in terms of race
gender and ethnicity and the reason that
I think is critical that we address this
is because we have the Civil Rights Act
dating back to 1964 that decreed that
race simply could not be considered in
some situations regardless of the
context nuances or Consequences
and employment and housing definitely
fall into those categories
after that the Fair Housing Act
extending from the Civil Rights Act
originally prohibit discrimination based
on race color religion sex or national
origin in 1988 they also had a
disability and familial status then the
Housing and the Community Development
Act was built to enforce the Fair
Housing Act it further supports special
projects including the development of
prototypes to respond to new or
sophisticated forms of discrimination
against persons protected so this idea
that government was explicitly putting
an act in that says that we need third
parties to go in and investigate
discrimination we have to make sure it
does not exist
and there was a format for doing this
there's a traditional audit that many of
you have probably heard of the most
common when you probably hear of is
people taking resumes and keeping the
exact same resume but changing the name
of it and maybe making one sound more
black and maybe having other name son
more white and submitting these and
seeing what happens in housing one of
the things that you do is you create
pairs of people matched on family and
economic features they successively
visit Realtors and researchers control
and isolate discrimination the first
national paired testings that happened
in 1977 the most recent one that
happened was in 2012 and as you can see
what people are told about and what
they're shown differs across different
categories and so discrimination I would
argue is getting better since we've had
some education since these laws have
been in place but still it's happening
in face-to-face visits and we found in
Edelman confirmed that it's happening in
online systems as well so we wrote this
paper in 2014 about auditing algorithms
and how do you take these algorithms and
find and find where this discrimination
or bias might be happening and again
because I went for aiming for shorter
talk and I'll try to be done in five
minutes so we can break out into groups
and have discussion but the result of
this paper ended up in a big data report
from the White House in May of this past
year and they named five nests
priorities that are essential to the
development of Big Data technologies and
one of them was algorithm auditing
specifically to promote academic
research in industry development of
algorithmic auditing and external
testing of big data systems to ensure
that people are being treated fairly
this was like a mandate by the US
government that said the team that
drafted this document many of them are
not going to be there after this week so
that that puts a cloud of ambiguity over
the future of this work that said as a
result of this my colleagues and I along
with colleagues at Northeastern and a
media company decided to pursue this
further with the government specifically
with the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act so
for those of you not so familiar with
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act this
criminal is a certain computer related
act so certain uses of CFAA have been
denounced by security and discrimination
researchers though who have commented
that what we could go to jail for all
security research at any moment so in
our lawsuit were basically claiming that
we would like to write as researchers to
investigate housing discrimination with
CFA a one of the things that's
interesting there is that it's
intentionally vague one of the theories
for CFA is I was created in 1980 after
on the Regan saw the movie wargames and
got really really scared so if you look
at some of the language in this it
states that whoever intentionally
accesses a computer without
authorization or exceeds authorized
access it's not quite clear what it
exceeds authorized access means and
thereby obtains information from any
protected computer shall be punished as
provided in subsequent subsection C of
this section and so forth but again is
this exceeds authorized access which is
a little confusing and ambiguous it's in
this exceeds authorized access language
has been repeatedly interpreted by
courts and the federal government to
prohibit accessing a publicly available
website in a manner that violates the
website's Terms of Service the result of
this is that the first violation carries
a one-year maximum prison sentence and a
fine
a second or subsequent violation carries
a prison sentence of up to ten years and
a fine and so in terms of service I mean
all of us oh I should say all of us
I often click on Terms of Service
without reading it um Terms of Service
are often written in a language that is
often in legalese very hard to interpret
but also some Terms of Service are a
little unexpected so this is a Terms of
Service for homes comm and it says that
without limiting the general generality
of other restrictions that for Thorian
you may not access monitor or copy any
content or information on this website
using any robot spider deep link scraper
or other automated means methodology
algorithm or device or any manual
process for any purpose does that mean I
can't take my pen and a piece of paper
and write down the price of this home I
mean by violating the CFAA and is this a
federal crime by my doing this
and so in and trying to close briefly
for discussion
I wanted to basically put a call to
action that designers have always faced
ethical questions about the harm caused
by the designs versus expected outcomes
and such benefits and I rather those
designers we need to think about some of
these outcomes upfront and build them
into our systems there are some
frameworks that have long been employed
and can be adapted to the online realm
but we also need to move beyond what's
already there and help communicate
algorithmic process and so if we are
going to do this this breakout that was
recommended I can see two different
approaches that we can go and look at we
can look at the algorithm audit and
think of how one might take one of their
favorite sites and create an audit for
it to find some type of bias or I would
argue someone can take their favorite
feed and think about ways outside of
typeface outside of you know control
panel to communicate that something
might be happening here under the hood I
prefer to talk about how the audit a
website that hasn't been audited before
that's option one option two was how how
a website might design redesign itself
to indicate some of the data that it
might be hiding to prefer option one
because you're here
up to do alright let's do that so we
haven't done this yet this quarter but
the way we'll roll is grab a small group
around you maybe on the order of five
six people and pitch around some ideas
how long you want to get peanuts five
minutes we have till 1:30 yeah ten
minutes all right let's go ahead and
give a very brief overview of our paper
and algorithm audits in terms of
auditing an algorithm there's some
approaches you can use you can get the
code from people often much much harder
than it looks but one person was kind
enough to give us code David Forsyth and
Robert Fleck they became they were this
this paper that got really famous in
1986 called finding naked people online
and one of the interesting things they
told us about this paper was that
originally it wasn't finding black
people online and so they had this
algorithm where he did the color of
processing the smoothing texture
extraction detect skin they actually had
to go in and modify their heuristic to
change the actual values to make sure it
caught black people and so an algorithm
audit we know one might argue that oh my
god this is clear discrimination you're
making a distinction between black and
white people or one might say look it's
it's people and other ways to ask the
users to do the audit which is what we
did with with fetus and so we brought
people to a lab and we got them there
another way is to collect data manually
to sit there with some paper and that's
exactly what Latanya Sweeney did she
went online looked at advertising and
found that if you put in a white name
like Cary
Swigert or Kerry you got ads like we
located Cary so and so if you put in a
black name
you got ad like Kisha family arrested
and she did all of this by hand
collected Ellis data manually the other
approach is just go ahead scrape galore
and I've already talked about some of
the problems with that many start up one
thing about today's startups often have
a disadvantage to other companies and
that they rely on scraping and
aggregating data from the web to exist
and if you're shut down for that before
you make it big or someone tries you
before you can make it big if maybe your
goal but if it's not your goal that can
be a problem and when we made this this
feed vis the API 1.0 let us use an API
if we wanted to recreate this today we
could not we would have to scrape
because as of April 2015 the 2.0 of the
API removed it sockpuppets was the next
approach and by a sock puppet
you're basically reading lots of
different identities throwing them out
there and seeing what happens similar to
some of the audit work that we talked
about and so for example Krista Wilson
found that if you go to Home Depot
different sock puppets got different
prices for the exact same product and
this is like a really fun project to do
if you're bored to Christmas to try to
say like how much the prices fluctuate
throughout the day throughout the week
and based on your location where you are
and finally my favorite approach is the
collective audit and this is the one
where I think that the group here is
most poised to to explore in many ways I
probably should have done this before we
went off into the design section but
this idea here this this site is called
bidding for travel calm is a bunch of
people discussing different prices with
using Priceline and gimmicks that they
can use to get the cheapest prices and
all sharing information together that
set is not organized in a way that's
easily legible and it requires you to
spend lots of time on it but how might
somebody do that
and I'm gonna pass the baton out to
Michael volunteers or maybe a video
explanation I description of what one of
the most interesting observations you
made was hey Ally you want to get up I'm
not sure what we start up to sharing
examples that we've encountered of like
potential bias and algorithm sent via to
what over like after they passed a
certain age threshold all their facebook
ads were for marriage and babies and the
Metro like I've never seen an ad for
that and I hate that because it enforces
these social norms and I personal
information here don't want to be
coerced or nudged into belonging to but
those ads they have an effect when you
see them like all day every day one of
my students told me that once she
changed her status on facebook from
singleton a relationship she was getting
engagement right it was funny that like
the three dudes are one so it's sort of
I don't weirdness of other people's
experience and like that's an obvious
one so yeah gender norms I'm really good
staring awkwardly until someone some
time like going through Facebook and
Twitter just looking the seat we should
get like a non-biased feel or not like
Taylor view of our feeds like maybe like
a truly phonological feed and there is
no way to do that would you found really
interesting so if nothing else like some
filtering options would be nice but we
all sort of been game it I really like
his idea of like I'm not similar to like
the inner circle an outer circle not but
like a non that just kind of changed how
to tailor your feet would be well
Facebook there is a extra button beside
the newsfeed and you click that you can
change actual place only sport for
timeline-based I'll cut it yeah it
revert back to top stories after a while
though yeah it's like if it's a
temporary temporary fridge one paper
there's someone else over here okay
yeah so they agree we kind of just
thought about it really when it comes to
a lot of these sort of vices that the
algorithm seems to produce it's a
sedative fact that the algorithm
themself algorithms themselves have this
bias it's the way that we sort of train
them ourselves right the only thing you
can really do is you can supply these
things with that and they can look at
that data and they can make their own
intuitions based on advice something
trying to make connections in relations
between the two so kind of going off of
what you proposed with the whole
democratic school on Twitter it's the
fact that the only that I haven't really
get to see is a liberal posting about
Donald Trump in the negative fashion now
I'm going to look at other articles and
say okay I got really hot so I'm gonna
say okay I'm looking at this and this is
this is trunk or hashtag and maybe take
these hashtags I'm going six on this
content and I want to say what else is
hot that other people won't see from
this so nice to know you have all of
these speeds they're constantly
populated with the same sort of use and
hashtags and subject matter on Trump
because there's not enough data for it's
weird to look at and say okay I can also
into it and say okay I see that this is
a positive article relationship chakras
so there's not enough of that content to
be there many other KLR so that's
interesting so you're suggesting that
like we know that we have these
demographic bins and we just request for
more data and once the data is missing
so very briefly you kind of look at the
situation of the earth connecting it and
the inmate and showing up if you can I
think about that you're really looking
like a much more developed form of
institutional racism a lot of data which
is within Google systems it's kind of
imprisons it's coming it's looking at a
lot of african-american names within the
system and maybe that kind of goes back
to a little bit of breaking air layering
with some of the whole crack rock being
which then leads to more Americans being
locked up in Caucasians because of the
accessibility cocaine versus crack rock
and so then you have that whole data set
is now a skewed sort of like in prison
all Google has to know from that is like
I see a connect in any prison but that
also touches on what happened with the
know Chicago minority reports I like
algorithms for predicting crimes the
exact same thing happened there and they
found that they were wrong which you
know suggests like typically we find
that algorithms are broken only when
something very bad happens after the
fact
do you feel that the the company that
the designers should they have foreseen
this
like should they have designed this into
the algorithm sort of pre-launch
or having seen it now is it that is the
onus on them that they need to fix it
I'm curious for your opinion on this
right like you have you kind of want to
say they know exactly what you are a
user based on Twitter but like you know
you never know Twitter was going to ask
you towards the millennial generation
and they better ask the millennial
generation with sin towards a liberal or
Republican bias years after you create
Twitter right so if you have this idea
this algorithm a couple years later this
new trend comes along within a certain
age group ends up using your
reflectional and you didn't expect these
may be your initial desire it's a nice
sort of soul chain sometimes I think
what you're getting at some level is a
an identity question for these platforms
I think Facebook as an example has often
viewed itself as sort of like this
neutral pipe that's connecting people
but I think one of the things that came
out of the discussions post-election had
to do with like it's it's not neutral at
some level that every design decision is
sort of tweaking one direction or
another or you're a media company at the
end of the day like there's news passing
through you and you have a
responsibility for that and as designers
I don't think we've really grappled with
that very effectively yet no and it's
it's weird because Facebook is sort of
performing the functions that utility
companies have performed to date but on
top of that you know providing opinions
and providing almost what's the word
providing guidance in a way that you
know the power company electric company
right could never do so give it one more
maybe from this column yeah we were
wondering sort of whether the old
speaking the results and biases are
there are in so because nation of like
algorithm are just a correlation between
like let's say race or all despised and
stuff maybe they just have like similar
culture way of speaking or stuff like
that that influences their big data to
sort of correlate into the same sort of
life as instead of just like the
algorithms itself using the directly
that
so by saying like oh because you're
let's eat black I'm gonna show you this
instead it's sort of like they have a
certain mannerism that gives them the
same data to result in some apps you
give this example the zip codes that
might be this way yeah so you know one
thing that's happening that's happened
in in advertising for years as the use
of zip codes and area codes which are
meant to be proxies for other
characteristics that should not have
been used and so one of things that we
were talking about at lunch was this
idea of you know proxy variables might
end up being used and even the actual
ones may have been created inside of
some sort of deep learning algorithm we
just don't know it and then we see these
outcomes at the end but have no way to
tell what's happening on the inside and
then designers wouldn't know that's
there yes to you about how you would
interrogate such algorithms in terms of
ethics so I could go in for hours about
this but there's deontological ethics
there's there's ethics that say that
it's all that matters is your intent
there's other ethics that say that all
that matters is the outcome and
depending on which ethical ideology you
subscribe to then you see what were the
law applies there but people haven't
looked at this people haven't looked at
this people have looked at law and
ethics in the past law and economics in
the past but I I imagine that lawmakers
are gonna have to take the syndic and
serious consideration for example more
recently Facebook just stopped
advertising about jobs and housing and
loans using a gender ethnicity race
because of a lawsuit so that's a
starting point but there was very
explicit there they knew that variable
if that variable switched to a zip code
or if that variable switched to some
other parameter that we don't know or
some weighted sum of parameters how do
we find that out how do we do these
audits and how do we follow that the
mandate that was given by the government
so many years ago to get third parties
to do it especially when they won't let
me walk into their vault and just say
I'm just gonna you know take this
algorithm and see what happens without
even having the training data is that
impossible to sort of have any form
classifying or filtering
system without sort of like eventually
gets pets or the outcome we're getting
those types of variables because the
only deal with big business try and from
this amount of day that you have and try
to figure out all the other day that you
can generate out of it so can you really
say that
can you really like consider it like
that's consider what exactly but you're
asking can you have personalized without
bias yeah okay so what you're saying
there so for ads like one thing I was
telling folks was like since coming to
San Francisco they had actually been so
much better than me than they've ever
been before and I've never actually
cleaned it out of my life maybe once
unintentionally but for once they
actually worked for me I don't have to
click on but you know I've looked ok I
can almost see why that's there and
there's this this idea than the future
that I believe that ads can be like a
communication between somebody where
this is exactly running at this right
time it's not there yet for example like
if I buy a wallet at Amazon for some
reason the next day it keeps advertising
for a wallet even though you probably
only need one a year maybe two years not
one a day so the systems aren't aren't
perfect yet but this idea of an
algorithm being personalized I think is
very beneficial
however when it comes to actually
breaking the law and hurting some people
over others the rich getting richer poor
getting poorer that's where the law
steps in and tries to use policy to
change it and what we're trying to state
is that maybe for these things we can
actually go in there and figure out
what's happening in the algorithms to
try to tweak them but not for everything
I mean personalization is great for many
things I mean I don't want to be
recommended books about I don't know
about you know I can't think of anything
I'm not interested in at the moment but
you know if you were to you know well I
can tell you what I would like I
wouldn't mind a book about a dinosaur
like I wouldn't mind a book about but
the other thing is that people don't
always use systems where they're
intended to be used so for example if
you were to look at my Netflix stream
you would see you know shows that I
watch and then somewhere in there
there's interspersed a Curious George
image and that's because a five-year-old
decided to take over my stream and use
it even though it's
for me and this happens all the time and
so those if these algorithms have
certain assumptions of how they're going
to be used we don't always use them that
way so we'll close here let's continue
the conversation offline we still have
the room if you want to stick around in
chat you can chat with Kerry in person
let's thank her one more time
you